[Musik]
klimaneutral das neue power wort im
konsumbereich findet man immer häufiger
im supermarkt soll bedeuten die
herstellung des produkts schadet dem
klima nicht
doch vorsicht stimmt das überhaupt
wenn heute irgendein produkt die mit
diesen begriffen wird weiß ich wirklich
nicht was gott substanziell dahinter
steckt wie so viele logos und man weiß
noch nicht einmal ob das dem klima
wirklich was bringt
wieso ist das denn so
dass vom privaten akteuren ins leben
gerufen es ist nicht staatlich
überwachten ich staatlich reguliert
klimaneutralität bei produkten ist also
eine freiwillige sache der hersteller
gesetzlich gibt es dafür keine
verpflichtung
aber so ein label macht sich halt
irgendwie gut auf der verpackung
doch was bedeutet der begriff
klimaneutralität eigentlich genau
der weltklimarat beschreibt das so
klimaneutralität ist ein zustand in dem
menschliche aktivitäten keine netto
auswirkungen auf das klima haben
klingt kompliziert ist es aber gar nicht
zunächst muss man wissen dass ganz viel
was wir so tun und wie wir leben co2 und
andere klimagase erzeugt und die haben
eben negative konsequenzen fürs klima
deshalb bedeutet klimaneutral in diesem
zusammenhang dass man die emissionen
thema möglichst weit reduzieren dann
verbleibt dann irgendwie kompensiert
so geht's also reduzieren und
kompensieren
reduzieren heißt den co2 ausstoß
vermindern beispielsweise hier am
hamburger airport wo man
elektrofahrzeuge einsetzt und grünen
strom nutzt und der rest an co2 die man
nicht vermeiden kann der wird
kompensiert also ausgeglichen
wettgemacht durch maßnahmen die dafür
sorgen dass anderswo gar kein oder
weniger co2 in die luft gerät wie
beispielsweise hier in indien oder im
kongo
dafür gibt es dann so genannte
kompensations zertifikate die man mit
seinem eigenen co2 verbrauch verrechnen
kann
nur so richtig nachprüfen kann man das
alles nicht auch weil es eben freiwillig
ist und
die gefahr dass möglicherweise die
eingesparte co2 menge sogar mehrfach
verrechnet wird ist durchaus gegeben
wer stellt jetzt aber sicher das nicht
dieses land in denen diese anlage stellt
das auch noch in seiner klimabilanz
anrechnen und dann wird sozusagen die
reduktion zweimal verbuchte man
sozusagen reduktion mehrfach verbucht
entsteht das risiko dass wird 2050 alle
klimaneutral sind aber die co2
emissionen in der atmosphäre immer noch
steigt
freiwillig undurchschaubar
unkontrolliert klimaneutralität ist er
eine behauptung und weniger realität
[Musik]
gilt das eigentlich auch fürs weit
verbreitete bäume pflanzen
eigentlich klingt es ja toll baum wird
gepflanzt der wächst und bindet durch
seine photosynthese co2 und gibt dabei
sogar noch sauerstoff an die umgebung ab
außerdem trägt das dazu bei zerstörten
bald wieder aufzuforsten und dient somit
der erhaltung bedrohter ökosysteme wir
machen jetzt einen ökologischen
waldumbau mit den pflanzen die wir
eingepackt haben und freuen uns darauf
dass wir hier für nachfolgende
generationen etwas kreieren können was
ganz viel lebensraum spenden wird und
ganz viel sauerstoff produzieren wird
bäume pflanzen für bessere luft und
biodiversität das funktioniert doch
genug co2 speichern endgültig das ist so
eine sache
wir haben mal nachgerechnet beispiel
buche pro jahr nimmt die rund 12,5
kilogramm co2 auf für eine tonne co2 im
jahr wären das also 80 buchen jeder von
uns verursacht aber im jahr rund elf
tonnen co2
das wären also über 800 buchen nur für
eine person
und das wäre nicht alles
damit die rechnung aufgeht müssen die
bäume mindestens 80 jahre leben das
schaffen die normalerweise aber jetzt
kommt die bäume dürfen danach weder
verbrannt werden noch verrotten denn
sonst würde sehr viel des eigentlich
gebundenen co2 wieder in die atmosphäre
gelangen und die frühere
klimaneutralität wäre futsch
aber wie lässt sich das verhindern
indem die bäume für immer luftdicht
verpackt gelagert werden
oder man sie sehr tiefer gräbt
ehrlich gesagt so was macht doch keiner
klimaneutral durch baum pflanzen nicht
sehr realistisch also wir von bled wir
haben nicht die lösung in denen wir
sagen pflanzt bäume und alles wird gut
das wäre viel zu einfach und zu schön
das ist nur ein schritt auf dem weg in
eine grünere gesündere zukunft
fazit klimaneutralität ist zwar eine
echt nette idee aber sie tatsächlich
richtig umzusetzen ist eher schwierig
[Musik]